unit 1 recording 14. what is
agribusiness to start with let's define
the meaning of the term agribusiness as
it becomes clear from the word structure
it consists of two concepts
agriculture and business
business is defined in oxford economics
dictionary as all forms of industrial
and commercial profit-seeking activity
so combined with agriculture
agribusiness means a particular branch
of economic and commercial activity
involved in the raising of crops and
domestic animals manufacturing and
selling of food and food products and
the next definition of business the
dictionary gives is the firm conducting
industrial and commercial activities so
combined with agriculture it implies a
farm or company which produces and sells
agricultural products food and
foodstuffs
so the next sections will focus on
commercial agribusinesses their
structure and types